au lendemain de leur rencontre à Kiev
avec le Président vous le dire ilanski
Anthony blinken et Lloyd Austin se sont
montré confiants le secrétaire d'État
américain comme le chef du Pentagone ont
indiqué que l'Ukraine pouvait gagner la
guerre contre la Russie
nous pensons que les Ukrainiens peuvent
l'emporter s'ils ont les bons
équipements et le bon soutien
la Russie a déjà échoué dans ses
objectifs de guerre parce que l'objectif
principal que c'était fixé le président
Poutine était de soumettre l'Ukraine en
l'intégrant la Russie de lui retirer sa
souveraineté et son indépendance cela ne
s'est pas produit et clairement cela ne
se produira pas
aux côtés du Président zellenski les
deux responsables ont annoncé le retour
progressif d'une présence diplomatique
américaine en Ukraine et surtout d'une
nouvelle aide militaire de 700 millions
de dollars dont 400 millions pour aider
les pays d'Europe de l'Est qui
fournissent des armes aux voisins
ukrainien les États-Unis ont
dernièrement accéléré les livraisons
d'équipements militaires à l'Ukraine des
armes lourdes notamment pour résister à
l'offensive russe qui se poursuit dans
tout le pays et qui se concentre surtout
à l'est et au sud de l'Ukraine à Mario
Paul les forces russes continuent à
bombarder le vaste complexe
métallurgique d'AST vostral où sont
retranchés les derniers combattants
Ukrainiens mais aussi près de 1000
civils prises au piège
cela fait un mois et demi que nos
enfants n'ont pas vu la lumière du
soleil
lundi le ministère russe de la Défense a
fait une énième annonce de cesser le feu
dans la ville portuaire dévastée pour
permettre les évacuations des
combattants et des civils aucune des
précédentes tentatives de couloir
humanitaire à Mario Paul n'a jusque-là
abouti